paul looking for help he finds bridges  three-pointer  no and brooklyn with the board jeff  green  secures it a chance for the nets to take  the lead  james harden for three oh he's got it  james harden with a big three-pointer  brooklyn for the first time tonight is  on top  wow  brooklyn stand up james harden  dagger 3.  [Music]  kyrie's taking care of herself you know  as far as back but those guys are you  know our biggest cheerleaders when  they're not playing  obviously we miss those guys they're  very very valuable to what we're trying  to accomplish but  once again uh guys stepped up uh tyler  bruce the entire team  landry uh joe jeff uh from top to bottom  guys played well and  uh we could have easily gave him that  game away you know over back to back  tired legs whatever excuse you want to  make but this is a resilient group and  we got a bigger picture